[Music]
13 o clock yeah I know we got something
we got some pretty good plan for the
hundredth episode I hope so yeah we get
started on that yeah we have a couple
different ideas but I think we'll work
it out it's funny because every time I
you know right before I start talking
like into the microphone at the
beginning of every episode I always feel
like I should you like The Tonight Show
theme anyway episode 92 now on this
episode like I said we like to kind of
go back and forth from true crime to
kind of more paranormally type of stuff
and we're going back on this one this is
kind of going back to our 40 and type of
thing where you know you remembered that
book that you had as a kid where you
know they're like the frog and the frogs
and everything like oh yeah yeah and
this was a similar thing and I brought
it up before my childhood book strange
stories amazing facts from readers
digest which came out in the 1968 1972
something like that and this actually
had a couple of these stories in it and
then I decided that add a third one too
because they're kind of all interrelated
sort of all right but uh so yeah on this
one we're doing let's call it phantom
attackers or diabolical attackers all
right we're doing Spring Heeled Jack
which has been requested the mad gasser
of Mattoon okay and The Devil's
footprints so they're like spectral
attackers oh yeah sort
are they confirmed crime cases like
police were involved that's what's
interesting about these because it's
possible particularly in the mad gasser
case that this could have been an actual
person okay that was doing some of these
but then you know and same thing with
Spring Heeled Jack it could have been a
person all right
although some of the things that are
reported are supernatural or aspects or
paranormal types of there but you know
it could be a thing where it was a
person and then like some kind of mass
hysteria in where people just started
adding all these crazy DV so it's gonna
be along the lines of Jersey Devils just
maybe a little bit it's something like
that and like I said a lot of these
three cases even though they took place
in you know different type in different
places
they're usually kind of all tied
together okay that type of thing alright
but before we do that let's kind of get
into our shoutouts and our news stories
and stuff like that obviously my book
the faceless villain I'm still working
on the second volume trying to get it
out this summer so it'll be out this
summer I swear I'm working very hard on
it and you know just spending hours and
hours a day and like I said the research
it takes a long time but it'll be out
this summer probably gonna get a better
microphone yeah eventually yeah before I
record the audio book yeah we're gonna
try to up the game on the audio
definitely want you had a few complaints
about audio quality and really it wasn't
much we could do it with the do about it
with the equipment that we had yeah so I
guess we have to move take it up a notch
yeah so you know we just had to bite the
bullet and get a microphone cuz I mean
you know this one is it's alright for
the podcast but for the audiobook I
think you have to have a better one also
if you haven't checked out our newest
movie review it was beyond reanimate er
yeah 2003 so go check that out if you
would like to and like I said that's
probably the last of our HP Lovecraft
ones for a while although we are going
to do a couple more in the upcoming
weeks yeah so yeah we got some more I've
got some more Lovecraft planned it's
just that we're not quite ready for you
yeah also be sure to check out our
Zazzle store at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock and there's t-shirts and a tote
bag check out our patreon page and our
blog at 13 o'clock podcasts at WordPress
com
which has a link to a PayPal account if
you'd like to make a one-time donation
if you'd like to financially support the
show and I'd like to also shout out to
our two newest patrons who are Brandon
and Victoria yeah thank you thank you
guys and yeah we're having a like a big
boom of new patients yeah patreon or
whatever
some people just send us money which was
very cool we always always appreciate
anything that you can send us yeah so
you know I got upping the audio quality
on the list because of all that - you
know we're getting more paid subscribers
so it's time to invest back into the
equipment for the show yeah also like to
mention our friends Adam Sain /
conspirator balls yeah that was fun we
recorded his show with them
we were pretty drunk yeah and the best
part of it is always their special
patreon yeah like we did like several
parts we mostly we talked about
different we talked about the podcast
and different topics yeah but then on
the patreon only one we talked about
movies yeah by then we were we were
pretty deep we were pretty yeah it was
fun hilarious
I was like kind of afraid the next day
because I'm like was I even being come
here and I'm not sure but they said it
was yeah it was just fine it was fun but
the meat and potatoes the pedestrian
show for the regular listener that was
just pretty much like a straight show it
took a while yeah what I'm saying
anymore I remember also I want to give a
shout out to a blog called beware the
zine evidently it's British and the
person that runs it had actually wrote a
review of our show and it's actually
very funny and it's very well written
okay this was brought to my attention by
one of our fans Gareth okay now Gareth I
apologize because last time I mentioned
Gareth I said he was Australian that is
not the case he was actually British Oh
we'll see what ended up happening is
that I have okay I have we have two
super fans yeah one of whom is British
and what if it was Australian okay and
as it happened they both sent me
messages on facebook at the same time
and for some reason like I mixed up like
I feel like I know where they're from
for some random when I was recording the
show like I forgot so I'm sorry I said
you were Australian okay I do actually
remember you from the UK and thank you
for pointing out that be where the scene
had reviewed us yeah you mentioned it
but I haven't read the review yet yeah
I'll have to read it to you it's
actually very funny okay and now our
Australian listener Matthew yeah he's
the one that always listens to our show
with all his chefs and stuff like oh
yeah yeah the whole kitchen crew yeah he
is opening a new restaurant Oh Brisbane
Australia cool yes the little social is
you take little social has he taken his
crew with him I like talking about I'm
not sure what five more details he'll
contact yeah yeah I have some details on
me in my facebook so I can actually put
little details in the description gives
us any information if you know if he
gives us enough information maybe some
photos you know we can plug his his
restaurant yeah I can make a little
commercial make a little commercial plug
his restaurant yeah yeah and I believe
it's opening I made 25th cuz he said
like the Friday so I'm assuming it's the
Friday after this show comes out so if
you're in the Brisbane area and
Australia and go check that new
restaurant out cuz that's one of our
superfans yeah whose restaurant that is
in that Nate alright so now let's kind
of do these are sort of also shout outs
but also sort of news stories the angry
gay Pope who has been on our show three
times yeah you know he was actually one
of on one of our very early episodes
like the fourth or nursing yeah so his
YouTube channel the end of Scientology
was taken down yeah now YouTube's policy
got him well in Scientology yeah what
ended up happening I mean the videos
that the Scientologists complained about
I've been up there for 10 years
yeah they suddenly he thinks that they
suddenly started complaining about them
because you know Scientology they just
launched their brand-new TV channel
right and they
want any competition they don't worry-
'ti so suddenly they pull this stuff out
of their ass and they just start
bombarding youtube with complaints about
his videos like I said which have been
up there forever and you know the
complaints that they're making are don't
have anything to do with the content
video and I'm assuming that they just
had so many and here's the thing
Scientology you know since their new TV
channel is starting and stuff like that
they actually paid a lot of money for
advertising yeah I have seen commercials
for this channel I like AMC right and
[ __ ] like that when I'm watching Walking
Dead it's the media has just atrophied
to the point to where they'll take
anybody's money they just lowered
themselves down to where they'll
actually even serve Scientology in this
way that's the thing Scientology is a
[ __ ] ton of money so it's like you know
a ton of money and nobody watches
television anymore
right so you know but yeah so anyway his
channel has actually gotten taken down I
think most of his videos have been
backed up Casey actually did lose his
channel before many years ago the end of
Scientology was actually his second yeah
he'll make a comeback site you will make
it he contacted me he was he was up he
was upset about it
and he contacted me through you know
just phone and just said man you gotta
diversify you know I would run run
another channel also you know something
you know maybe like urban exploration
because you know I've been thinking
about that you know can you have one
show long you know kind of launching
another show so you kind of diversified
with more than one gig and it's all kind
of self supports yeah and one one
promotes another so I think that's
probably I was gonna do it he was also
getting denial of service attacks on his
aggregate Pope website I believe he said
it was yeah although that's still I just
wish there were yesterday and it's still
there and he has a patreon too so if you
can like go and support him as well yeah
anger gave up under attack you know I
mean he could use all the help in the
world and we were actually kind of
worried about it because he'd been on
our show three times we were kind of
worried that like now
is gonna come after our show and get our
entire show shut down just go sit be
[ __ ] because yeah because if you if
you go on YouTube and you search angry
gay Pope our videos come up number one
video yes is now that he's gone what
yeah are so our interviews with him are
the first ones that come up and so I
actually what I did was I actually just
changed them to private oh you did so
just the three that we had with him just
until it all blows over because I don't
want Scientology crawling up my ass yeah
I'm getting our whole entire channel set
down shut down rife with only three of
our videos everything about that right
because if you don't have vindictive and
spiteful those bastards are yeah and
they have lawyers you know what I mean
so what they'll do is they'll say well
what little things have this channel
what rules have they broken and we'll
focus on that and if you look at
YouTube's policy everybody's breaking
rules and three buddies that means you
know they could just take any video
where they want down pretty basic so
yeah if someone gave them enough
complain they'll take your videos yeah
if someone bitched at them enough then
right and if they and if you have three
Community Guidelines strikes that take
your whole channel down rush means that
we'd have to make another 13 o'clock
which that brings me to another subject
we got to start getting on other
platforms because YouTube just can't be
trusted we gotta have them maybe what's
what's some of the other well I kind of
thought of posting maybe posting them on
dailymotion dailymotion
female baby minds there's a bunch of
other ones that I think mine's just
kidding I mean I have all the videos
backed up yeah so it's not like I mean
it would be a pain in the ass I can't
destroy can't destroy our material they
can only destroy this channel and we
just have to move it somewhere else yeah
which is exactly what I'm really I'm
thinking we need to start planting the
seeds on other plants so if this one
ever got shut down by some kind of a
mutual enemy like Scientology it
wouldn't really affect us that much just
the traffic was shift over into more
established channels that we already had
somewhere else yeah it's just not safe
to run YouTube alone you can't trust you
- yeah but like I said I've got all the
shows backed up so you know if any and
and all the audio ones I have posted
elsewhere right so you know the audio
doesn't have anything to do with YouTube
okay so the only other news story that I
wanted to mention was that guy Lyon
Playfair the famous parapsychologist but
probably best known for his work on the
Enfield poltergeist case yeah and his
book this house is haunted has passed
away
yes guideline flavor has become one with
the force yes he died on April 8 2018 so
behind some really good poltergeist
material yes definitely go out and get a
copy of this house is haunted
it's a very good and actually that book
was sort of like the template that I
wanted to use when I wrote the unseen
hand because it's very matter of fact it
doesn't embellish anymore it'll have
negative reviews boy it's so dry and
boring that's because it's nonfiction
yep telling you what yes not making it
like a movie and like I said that was
that was really what I took away from
that book and what I really liked about
that book because to me I thought it
made its barriers yeah I thought it was
very that found the book after I had my
own poltergeist case happen with my
family I found it years later when I was
a teenager in high school and I read it
and I go this is what happened to us and
my family it is poltergeist you know I
wasn't really sure what to call what
happened to us and you know that stories
in mouth not poltergeist Jenny did a
beautiful job on it well in that book is
kind of like kind of in that same vein
yeah as this house is haunted
it's like you want to get a good book
like an interest
yeah you know you don't want to like
embellish things you know you got to
stick true to the story yeah which Oh
which reminds me I got a you got a
record some more for NPR no man I got to
get to that - so we got a contact NPR
record about another 15 minutes of
material that they need it was recorded
here okay all right we can do that now
let's get into our main topics so the
first one I want to talk about is Spring
Heeled Jack yeah this is not this is
this isn't Spring Hill Jim from
Morrissey right no okay well Spring
Heeled Jack is a very I mean I he's
probably pretty well-known in the u.s.
too I guess but but he's a very
well-known like folkloric thing in
British history because that's where the
first stories came about and like later
on there were a lot of like fictional
you know there's a penny dreadful about
him and stuff like that okay the weird
thing about this figure is that like I
said he seems almost like it could be a
dude right like doing this kind of stuff
but then all this other like kind of
confabulation happen around him until
suddenly now he's almost like kind of a
demonic or a supernatural kind of figure
okay so here's the thing we're going
back to London 1837 now there are
actually two reports from 1837 of
spring-heeled Jack
although these didn't come out until
later on okay but these were allegedly
the first sightings of him all right
they were discovered much later yeah so
we don't know if they're actually right
these came out like later on this
actually happened in it was in October
1837 now apparently this girl Mary
Stevens she was a maid or a servant or
something like that she was walking from
Battersea where she had been visiting
her family to Lavender Hill and when
she's walking through like passes alley
or something like that this guy jumps
out on her and starts like but basically
like a sexual assault start staring at
her clothes starts trying to kiss her
all this other kind of stuff the only
weird thing about that was that she said
that he had claws and that his grip was
cold and clammy like a corpse so that
like I said that
could be a death sounds plausible like
something good like that could happen it
does however the following day evidently
several witnesses reported a guy that
kind of looked like what she described
jumping in front of a carriage which
made the carriage driver freak out and
he like steered the carriage late turned
over and he got hurt and then a bunch of
witnesses who saw the accident said that
the guy that had jumped in front of the
carriage then jumped over a nine-foot
wall laughing and babbling and like a
very high-pitched sort of noise he was
making so they're saying he jumped
straight up right no you can't jump over
a nine-foot wall I know unless you're a
tall guy and you can grab the top of the
wall swing yourself over so they're
saying he jumped over it and his feet
less bullying maybe it appeared to be
that way though right but that was first
that the first unusual thing is like
this thing like okay never a nine-foot
well okay now this report where does it
first appear that I don't know you don't
know it's just part it's just pow
infrared oh right right like I said
these came out later okay
now when the story started to get
widespread was in about January 1838 and
this was when the Lord Mayor of London
he was having they were having like a
little public session or whatever and he
says I got this letter from some guy in
Peckham and he says that there were
these two upper class twit guys he
didn't say who they were or anything
like that but he's like oh well
evidently I'm hearing rumors that there
was a wager between these two men that
one of the guys would go around town
dressed up in various costumes either a
ghost a bear or a devil or a demon type
of thing and he would go around like as
a prank like scaring the [ __ ] out of
people
that sounds very dangerous yeah I think
I think 1830s in England I still I think
that civilians at that time could own
firearms so you might get your ass shot
off well yeah I think 1830 I think at
least noblemen probably had access to
guns because you couldn't get away with
that in the deep south you go around
scare some people those deep south today
Union shot
we'll see that's why I always wonder
about like all these people that do
pranks like I'm gonna go dress up as a
clown yeah go stand in the dark and
creepy people out that's very dangerous
even another country even other
countries even in other countries even
if you people don't have guns you're
still gonna get your ass stabbed or
rushed in the face or something like
that it's a dumb thing to do but the
funny thing is that the Lord Mayor he is
quoted as saying it says the wager has
been accepted in the unmanly villain has
succeeded in depriving seven ladies of
their senses two of whom are not likely
to recover but to become Bourbons to
their friends so apparently this letter
that he had received said that there was
some kind of like nobleman that was
going around playing pranks dressed up
like a ghost or like a devil he was
going around to lay these doors and
making them faint and go into this or
whatever like the Victorians do now even
at this stage now the Lord Mayor is
still thinking this is a guy yeah but
then it's like after that public session
there was another public session a
little while later and he had this big
stack of letters and all these people
around various parts of London had
written to him and said yeah like there
was a guy and like he jumped on me in an
alley or he came to the door or
something like that at first like I said
they think it's a person but some of the
reports had some weird little details
like some of the women said that the guy
had metal claws or what looked like
metal claws and later on some said that
he had spits blue flame at them or white
flame at them this would make an awesome
movie I think well it has been made into
several plays you know he's a comic book
character stuff like that and also that
he had like red reflective eyes like I
said just like in the reports about the
carriage a lot of people said that he
could bounce really high like he could
go for it from the street to the roof
and he was always like jumping from roof
to roof and some like he could jump
really high and one go well you know
there may be something
because you can look at some who are
those acrobat acrobatics a layer or like
harcourt by parkour type guys maybe
there was a guy around that was doing an
early form of that all right young guy
the buildings the buildings in London at
that time you know well actually
probably all across English cities were
built really close to one another
yeah so if you got top on top of one
it's easy to jump to the other there's
only a few trained so the modern
sensibilities would be really impressed
by all the jumping across rooftops and
you're imagining an American city George
but across those rooftops would take
Superman but jumping across rooftops of
English buildings of the day that's
maybe the alley is whirling three or
four feet across yes there is one wall
to another might have been somebody Khan
doing parkour you know no version of
that you know you had young guys
dreaming up crazy stuff going way back
off you know it's just in the nature of
young men to cool I feel like that
should be the title of your
autobiography cool and stupid [ __ ] fools
do behold my beer all right now probably
the the original story about Spring
Heeled Jack that I read in my strange
stories amazing facts book which kind of
captured my imagination back when I was
a kid it had these two these two
particular reports in it because these
are probably the two most famous ones
the first one of these happened on
February 19th 1838 and this was a girl
named Jane Alsop and she was in her
father's house someone knocks at the
door and she opens it the guy says I'm a
police officer
we've caught Spring Heeled Jack over
here in this street right bring me a
candle so she brings us the guy a candle
huh and she's all excited I'm gonna see
spring he'll drink hot all right and
then the guy he had like a cloak on and
he throws the cloak off and the quote
that she gave was he presented a most
hideous and frightful appearance okay he
vomited blue and white flame from his
mouth yeah
and his eyes resembled red balls of fire
we see this isn't as crazy as it sounds
no it does you can put pure alcohol in
your mouth and if you have a lit match
or something like that around of course
you can blow fire people blow fire today
and if you're looking at the right angle
that fire would reflect back in your
eyes they would look like red eyes yeah
and maybe if somebody back in those days
you know hadn't really seen that trick
before they might be very impressed
that's what I was thinking right
and she also reportedly flame it's blue
that's alcohol yeah in those days Frank
gin yeah she also reported that he was
wearing a big helmet yeah and that
underneath his cloak he had like a
really weird like a tight-fitting outfit
like a white oil skin evidently then he
started grabbing at her and stuff and
she screamed and then he ran away
that sounds like a guy dressed up to be
beinac that's what I mean and and this
description of spring-heeled jack is
probably the most widespread room with
the oilskin the cloak the red eyes the
flames the claws yeah yes so that's
usually when people say Spring Heeled
Jack that's usually the the description
that they use now there was another one
eight days later February 28th there was
this other girl named Lucy scale she was
18 and she and her sister had been
visiting their brother he was a butcher
and they were walking down an alley or
something like that
they see a person that's kind of
standing in the shadows and then they
walk by him and he jumps out with the
cloak and he starts spitting blue flame
at them Oh
lined in her and she kind of like
dropped to the ground and yeah this is
this again this is the this is the
cockney Batman yes kind of like that
yeah so the thing is after those two
particular cases were publicized in the
media yeah now it should be noted that I
don't think and from what I've read I
don't think the second attack yeah had
been or the first attack had been
published in the paper before the second
one so it's not like they're just
reading it and saying oh yeah I saw that
[ __ ] do you know what I mean I'm so not
real clear about that so then the the
legend kind of starts to spread outward
now everybody's seen it and in a way he
starts getting more diabolical in
appearance at some times he has horns
you know sometimes it's
you know the red flames coming out of
his eyes like he jumps from the street
he jumps like 20 feet in the air that
kind of stuff yeah an interesting thing
too was that the first time that the
Jain Alsop sighting was reported in the
papers in the London Times I believe it
was they actually said that there was
this guy named Thomas Milbank and that
he had been arrested like shortly
afterward and he had said in a pub
according to witnesses that he was
Spring Heeled Jack well you know that
there'd be a lot of guys bragging that
is yeah so he got arrested for that and
when he was arrested but wasn't what
would be the crime harassment well yeah
he was like grabbing women and licks on
Adam and you know what does everyone
anyone that actually injured though not
doesn't sound like me and it doesn't
sound like anybody's been killed or
seriously injured no it sounds like that
it's to me it sounds like a prank that's
kind of what I'm going for it now if you
could actually confirm that these
stories date back to that time and they
weren't things that were invented much
later I have to say that this probably
happened I think yeah like I'm saying
some of the other reports that maybe
happen later on probably could have just
been people saying that they saw the
same thing interestingly this Thomas
Milbank fellow who had said in the pub
yeah I'm totally spring-heeled Jack when
he was arrested he was wearing an outfit
very much like the one Jane Alsop said
he had like white overalls he had a big
cloak where do you what do you do freely
and they found a dropped candle I don't
know it didn't that weight wonder what
the white jumpsuit is all about is that
just you know was that a common
workman's clothes I don't think so
because it's it's mentioned so a lot so
it must have been something unusual all
right but the interesting thing was he
wasn't convicted for anything because
her account said that he had breathes
fire and Thomas Milbank is like I can't
do this
so he got but after this after these
reports and after the whole Thomas
mailbag thing then the character just
like took on a life of its own then it
started being like a demon they started
writing plays about it like even the
Punch and Judy little puppet shows at
the time they even changed the name of
the devil
spring-heeled Jack so they started to
kind of conflate those two characters
together and then there were all these
like fictional stories about them like I
said there was a penny dreadfuls plays
that type of stuff so at that point you
know the the legend kind of spread out
and it almost became not so much just a
person going around causing crisis like
now it's like this devil yeah or you
know this supernatural type of figure
and one of the most famous sightings
from later on was from 1877 and
apparently there were all of these
soldiers in these barracks in alder
shots I guess I'm pronouncing that right
and evidently there was a Centurion the
camp and he looked out into the dark and
he saw a when he called a peculiar
figure coming toward him and the soldier
says hey what are you doing there
and then the figure came up adamant
started slapping him in the face at
which point the guard shot him but it
didn't do anything right or so they say
and that was actually a hallmark of
another sighting too that they shot at
the dude and it didn't do anything there
was you know other sightings later on
but none of them quite as spectacular
now as you said really even from the
beginning of the phone.i with the Lord
Mayor coming out saying I got all these
letters from this guy they were pretty
sure that this was a person dressing up
in outfits and trying to scare the [ __ ]
out of people just because they were
being a dick or they thought it was mine
or whatever it was it was like Victorian
jackass right yes
now one of the people that is usually
associated with the fenomena was the
Marquis of Waterford otherwise known as
the mad Marquis okay now this guy kind
of a young aristocrat and you know
rumors about him kind of started
circulating way back in the 1840s and he
was kind of known for being kind of a
jerk you go around being kind of a
vandal he would you know plead cruel
pranks on people he wasn't a big fan of
women he liked it you know go around
kind of Claude I'm and [ __ ] like that I
got into fights he drunk a lot so he
actually was in the area when the first
incident took place now he actually died
in 1859 and there were some sight
spring-heeled Jack after that but the
main ones were before that so they kind
of think maybe this guy did some of the
early ones and then maybe some of the
later ones were imitators or were mass
hysteria or something of that nature
yeah
and like I said this is a very not so
much in the United States but in the UK
very very popular folk figure yeah tons
of stuff right about it but even like
recently like I said I think there's a
British comic book that actually sort of
had Spring Heeled Jack is sort of the
superhero yeah it's like a bad figure
okay well you pretty much kind of
covered it if you ask me I think
probably what the deal was is that you
had a situation comic we have in the
United States with the clown sightings
yeah killer cats I know what I was
thinking right we have a band called ICP
the insane clown posse and their fans
are known as Juggalos those are
hilarious if you ask me and at least one
of them I think it's a bunch of them we
dress up in clown masks and go out and
scare the kids
yeah no no the cotton this is happening
in the hood and the cops have warned
them this is man don't go down there's
fear in those kids you're gonna get shot
I don't think it's one Juggalo I think
it was a couple of them you know they
hear about a report of one guy doing and
then another one would spontaneously go
dress up as a killer clown and let the
kids see me you know it's gonna [ __ ] out
the kids well that could go bad pretty
quickly you know in the neighborhoods
that they're doing it in you know yeah
you know this guy's never gonna be found
and that's how I think what you had here
probably what you had is you had at one
time a real acrobatic guy who could
probably blow fire maybe he worked at a
you know like a carnival yeah or maybe
he was an actor or just a professional
Acrobat he could do some parkour type
stuff and blow fire take a bottle of gin
pour it in his mouth and was just
running around having fun with people
one thing led to another he's up in his
game he's adding metal claws or he's
adding things to his ol his outfit yeah
come more and more fearsome it doesn't
sound like anyone who was actually
injured maybe the minor injuries it's
like some woman's like one she was
temporarily blinded by the flames
because they believe the flames in her
face not gonna happen
right you know so it's not like he was
killing anyone yeah and it wasn't like
he was scratching people up it sounds
like he was just a prankster and an an
acrobat showing off his abilities look
at me you know yeah and you tripping
people out for all you know he might
have been a 17 year old kid and then you
had copycats and the legends grew yeah
like I said is it as it's started to
appear in the media you know other
people might have got the idea to do the
same thing or people might have been
making false reports saying yeah that's
not - and I don't believe he was jumping
over nine-foot walls in a Cell bout I
think he was going over them it's just
that he was doing it in such a
flamboyant way that the observer
boy it seemed like he you know jumped
you know in a single leap like Steve
Austin you know Six Million Dollar Man
jumping up and landed on he did
something real acrobatic and it looked
cool and yeah interestingly one of the
later fictional stories about him
whoever wrote the fictional story
actually gave him spring boots and they
said that's how they doing that he had
made these boots that Springs on the
mini good boy like that if you have two
buildings close together in a real
narrow alleyway there are parkour guys
that can jump up those get on the top of
the tops of those buildings and I
guarantee you those alleyways were
narrow enough yeah those all probably
just gets you can do that back in those
days sir and all it would take was just
one inventive teenaged Acrobat to figure
that out
he just right Mantha right and he would
be seen as a superhuman monster and
those that in those in that era yeah
sure interesting thing too is that the
video game Elder Scrolls 4 which came
out in 2006 one of the little things
that you can get in the game is called
boots of spring-heeled Jack yeah they
make you jump higher and stuff it's
quite cool I'm leaning towards that this
is something that actually happened
although I think it also spurred a lot
of legends yeah like I said some of the
original ones even even like you said
the fire-breathing the red eyes and
stuff but that could be explained by
normal means there's somebody just being
like theatrical play sounds like a
circus acrobat yes right and then later
on it got even a boil
close they're talking about sounds like
something a professional would wear
he's got the cloak is that like skin
tight skin tighten an oilskin you know
that's kind of flame-retardant
yeah and if you're blowing fire you're
gonna need something to keep yourself
from catching on fire right but you're
hiding that flame-retardant suit by
putting an impressive cloak over it that
looks really cool and if that catches on
fire you can dump the cloak and you
still got this oil skin protective fire
retardant suit
somebody who knew what they were doing
this is said he had a helmet well a
couple of the reports that he had a
helmet if you're doing hardcore parkour
between buildings and jumping across
rooftops that might be a good idea to
get some head protection well yeah
because if you follow you'd be yeah
there's something to it yeah I do the
story interestingly too there was also
between 1939 and 1945 in what was then
Czechoslovakia there were reports of a
similar dude who later became known as
the spring man of Prague and he was seen
at a bunch of places similar kind of
description yeah so don't know if it was
just another guy copying it because like
I said this was later we had one here
recent times he was called spider-man he
was as he was 82nd airborne infantry vet
and the guy was climbing the balconies
on the outsides of people's apartment to
rob their apartments they see him
climbing 20 stories up in the air
climbing from one balcony to the next
because he had a bunch upper body
strength and no fear of heights
climbing up people's balconies
spider-man yeah you got caught that well
I mean the same thing the guy that
turned up in Czechoslovakia whether it
was a real guy or not same as the
British one he eventually became kind of
a folklore ñeuro type the Wikipedia page
says that this character who's called I
don't know if I'm pronouncing this right
but it's per rack maybe he starred in
several animated superhero cartoons
fighting the SS Nazis and jumping around
crazy boots and stuff like that yeah so
alright we're a little bit past the
halfway point now so we're gonna take a
break and then when we come back I want
to talk about the mad gasser of Mattoon
also another kind of phantom attacker
but maybe there was a real dude behind
it that just kind of okay got conflated
later on so we will be back in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh right and we're back yeah
now this is kind of an interesting story
this known as the mad gasser of Mattoon
although the interesting thing about
this it actually happened in 1944 in
Mattoon Illinois however what I only
just recently discovered before we
started recording this show was that in
Virginia in 1933 there was an almost
identical outbreak so I don't know if it
was like the same person or if it was a
copycat
or something this goes back to the to
the first part of show we were talking
about Spring Heeled Jack one of the most
important factors is the dates you have
to be able to confirm that the reports
are from the place and time so long as
you can do that then you know if you can
actually kind of nail it down to where
yeah this is a good report from a
reliable witness or a reliable source
and it is contemporary from that time
then the the chances of the occurrence
being true actually go up quite a bit
you know if you ask me
so like Spring Hill I go tell my Spring
Hill Jim did it happen if the dates
check out then yeah it probably did and
if the dates check out on this kind of
stuff then maybe it happened it's you
know as long as the claims are not too
fantastic the interesting thing about
these mad gasser stories is that they're
not necessarily they didn't really take
on a supernatural aspect until later but
the interesting thing about them is that
it could it's totally feasible that it
could be a person but the interesting
thing is that there wasn't really a lot
of evidence left behind if this indeed
was a person because there were a lot of
attacks now generally like I said mad
gasser of Mattoon is the more famous one
that happened in the
forty-four but in I don't over
pronouncing this either but it voted
tort County I guess is how you brothers
in Virginia in 1933 evidently it was a
few days before Christmas and this is
the first known attack okay okay so it's
about ten o'clock at night and there's
this missus Cal Huffman and she's in her
house and she said that she smelled of
strange gas like she suddenly smelled
something in her house and she started
feeling really nauseated so then she
goes to bed her husband stays up and
sees if he can you know see anybody
outside he doesn't see anybody but that
half an hour later another wave of gas
comes into the house and so he they
called the cops and everything so the
cops come and then there's another one
like also all this gas is like coming in
the house now the gases but they smell
it and did the cop smell it also
evidently now it says the victims
reported that the gas caused them to
become very nauseated
they got headaches and their mouth and
throat muscles muscles constricted okay
now is there any way we can actually
confirm that this is a true this thing
it said this was this was evidently a
police report as far as I know as far as
we know yeah now they said that the this
family the Huffman's they had a 19 year
old daughter and she was the one most
affected by the gas she actually had to
be put on a respirator for a few days
she had convulsions for a few days
following that oh one second this is 30s
right nice to 34 yet did they use gas to
run doesn't run the ovens it's
interesting because in the first gasser
reports from the 40s that happened in
Illinois that was actually the first
thing most people thought of they said
well maybe something's wrong with the
pilot light right but a lot of them said
that the gas didn't smell like that it
smelled real unusual a lot of them
reported that it smelled really sweet
the interesting thing too later is that
a lot of the later reports said that the
gas not only made them sick but also
paralysis like it caused their legs to
weaken or the earth they woke up they
couldn't get out of bed you know that
sounds like what's that sounds like
something based on opium yeah possibly
has kind of a grape smell to it maybe
that's what they're taught me some buddy
was using some kind of an opium gas
something that knock people out I said
yeah so evidently this this nineteen
year old girl she was taking the doctor
now they couldn't figure out what kind
of gas they said well some of it might
have been miss area Visionnaire she's a
girl you know but they did say there was
um gas but they couldn't figure out what
gas it was they said they were able to
rule out it wasn't chloroform
it wasn't ether it wasn't tear gas but
they couldn't figure out what it was now
they said that underneath a window of
this house they did find footprints
interestingly they were women's shoe
prints like high-heeled shoes and this
was something that would be reported or
that would be found in a few of the
other attacks yeah that it was like a
woman's shoes evidence so there were a
bunch of these attacks over the year in
this particular place yeah where people
were saying they would be in their house
or they would wake up or they would be
in their house in the evening and then
they would smell something it would make
them sick it would give them paralysis
or give them various other things you
know and then sometimes they would find
footprints under their window sometimes
their screen would be slashed although
nobody ever broke in or anything like
that a few times prowlers were seen on
the property but they could never be
apprehended you know this reminds me of
what's that
there's a real famous terrorism incident
over in Russia where some chicken rebels
took over a movie theater they had
suicide bombers they you know female
suicide bombers and guys and the Russian
SWAT teams used gas to try to put them
all to sleep put everybody to sleep yeah
theater so they could go in there and
get well the gas that they used was kind
of a kind of a morphine type based gas
and it's nearly impossible to dose in
that situation it killed a lot of the
people that were in there but they were
they were able to successfully complete
the mission even though they killed a
lot of civilians with this gas because
you know how do you dose it right yeah I
mean the people in the back of the
theater got most of it and they just
fell asleep and died from overdoses yeah
but you know they're thinking of the the
thinking and anti-terrorism was well
they're gonna die anyway so the ones
that survived are the ones that he saved
and it kind of reminds me of that maybe
somebody was going up to Windows and had
some kind of nope opioid based gas and
was pumping it into houses in order to
knock people out so they could get in
there with impunity and go through the
house yes Robin it's incredibly
difficult to do to get the dosages right
yeah there doesn't affect somebody or it
kills them so maybe it was somebody with
some trying to perfect a way of knocking
people out in the house so they could go
in there Robin yeah although like I said
no none of the houses were ever really
robbed and it didn't seem like anyone
was usually trying to get in so it's
weird because I mean like I said all of
these cases took place in Virginia in
the 30s but the more famous outbreak
happened in Mattoon Illinois in 1944
maybe was a situation where somebody
goes up to a window and tries to put a
pipe through a window and pop gas in
there and then they're looking in from
the outside and waiting for the gas to
take effect it never take never gives
the desired effects they never go in
maybe something like that but like I
said it's it's just weird because I
think in later years the mad gasser of
Mattoon story kind of became synonymous
with mass hysteria it was even the
subject of like a case study okay in
mass hysteria
but in a way I think that almost kind of
does it and deserve a disservice because
even though probably some of the later
accounts like after the media made such
a big deal about it um you know then
anytime anybody smelled anything weird
at my house or saw a shadow outside
their window to be like oh my god it's
about gas oh yeah well they're reading
that they're reading in the newspaper
that this is happening so they become
paranoid right paranoid and
oversensitive to the fact that maybe
somebody's creeping around trying to
pump gas into your house right so you
know even though there were a lot of
reports of it you know maybe a couple of
them were true but maybe it was only one
or two and then when those were reported
and like I said it was kind of
completely why this big thing right but
the more famous one that happened in
Mattoon like I said this was in 1944
note the mad gasser of Mattoon or the
an aesthetic prowler The Phantom Anessa
anesthetist now the first one of those
actually happened on August 31st 1944
and this was a guy named urban Rafe and
he woke up in the middle of the night
and he said he smelled something weird
then he said that he felt really sick
and he felt weak and then he started
throwing up now the first thing he
checked was the pilot you know they said
yeah that's there was nothing there now
later on that same night there was
another neighbor who lived close by and
she said that she woke up in the middle
of night because she heard her daughter
coughing and hacking but then she found
that she couldn't get out of bed like
she was paralyzed the day following that
this was September 1st
there was a woman named mrs. Kyra knee
and she reported smelling there was a
really really sweet very very strong
odor that came into her house this was
about 11:00 p.m. at night now she at
first thought well maybe it's just
flowers that she's oh it was a floor
very strong floral smell so she's like
well maybe it's just flowers but the
odour just got like stronger and
stronger and then she started her legs
started becoming paralyzed so she her
and her sister called the cops and the
cops came but they couldn't find
anything they couldn't find any gas they
couldn't find any footprints or anything
like that but when her husband came home
about an hour later he said that he saw
a dude outside hiding now the
interesting thing about this and this if
you ever look up for artwork of the mad
gasser of Mattoon this is what he always
looks like and it's from this guy's
description he said the Prowler was a
tall man dressed in dark clothing
wearing a tight-fitting cap most of the
time he's also reported as having a flip
gun which you know that's the
agricultural thing they spray pesticide
with you know it looks kind of like a
bicycle pump yeah that type of thing
he often is reported in at that now
interestingly though a lot of the later
reports in Mattoon Illinois some of the
people said that the Prowler that they
saw looked like a woman dressed as a man
now if you'll remember the attacks that
happened earlier something face off high
heels shoes although if you're going to
go around like that
people's houses why would you work as a
man why would you wear high heels yeah
because that's maybe she wasn't
originally dressed as a man yeah so even
though so there were a bunch of other
reports later on after that
okay reported no this is taking place in
how large of an area these cases it's
pretty much all in one town and like the
outline there could have been some crazy
old women yeah so I'm thinking honey I'm
just material yeah houses for unknown
maybe crazy reason maybe she's trying to
reduce the the value of the property so
she can get into the real estate
business or drive people out because
they're sinners their sake might be
something that I mean some people like I
said if this was indeed a real person
doing this I think people are saying
like oh well maybe they were just trying
to gas everybody in there like to so
they could break in even though no one
ever broke in I'm like you know maybe if
this was a person maybe it was just a
crazy person yeah that's crazy you just
thought it was funny to like spray gas
yeah probably more so along the lines of
they sinned against God it's gonna be
something like that Jesus told me to do
it yeah or you know it's gonna be a
really crackpot reason now you know the
police did respond to a lot of these
reports now the they didn't find any
clues at most of the early scenes
however on September 5th
this was this couple named Carla Beulah
Cortes they were in the house and then
they saw like a white cloth like a
hankerchief like on their porch and
apparently Beulah picks up the cloth and
smells it and then starts to get really
really sick so she said that she starts
vomiting she said it felt like an
electric shock and her face swelled up
she got a burning sensation in her mouth
and throat and she also reported
paralysis in the legs
now she thought she's like well usually
our guard dog slept on the porch so
maybe this gasser came up there and put
this cloth you know by the dog to knock
the dog out or something like that she
said she also found a skeleton key on
the porch um the interesting thing
though is when this cloth was analyzed
they couldn't find anything unusual on
it like no kind of drug or anything so
at this stage they're kind of thinking
okay well maybe this is a real
but who but what gasps could this be
that's causing this these types of
symptoms now they said that one that
actually does do that is carbon
tetrachloride or a trial or
trichloroethylene both of those smell
very sweet and they can cause symptoms
much like the ones people were reporting
now it turned out that there was a big
factory in this town called Atlas
Imperial and they did have both of these
chemicals on their property but they
weren't there in really a large enough
amount right who has to have just kind
of drifted out into the town and they
said you know even if that had happened
then obviously the people who worked
here would have been effects right much
prior to you know when distressed into
people's houses and stuff like that but
they they did say that those two
chemicals could cause that so maybe
that's what this person was using yeah
it's not a camera it's not a
conventional chemical leak this this
what they're talking us basically
terrorism it does sound like some kind
of weird terrorism having to do some
crazy person running around pumping gas
if if these if these complaints check
out if they're actually from that time
and they're from sources that are
reliable and that's probably what was
that yeah and like I think some of it
was hysteria yeah I kind of think like
maybe the early ones were probably a
crazy person go around there for real
sorting gas into people's houses but
then as the hysteria grew it got
reported in the media and then I mean it
got to a point where cops in Mattoon
they were getting so many reports of it
that they just started ignoring them
because their most of them were I mean
watch it I can kind of relate to the
story because I once had a look propane
linked an accidental propane link a leak
in a house with a propane driven dryer
no clothes dryer yeah and I took care of
the leak the leak was gone but there I
kind of had this weird psychosomatic
feeling you know I mean that I was still
being gassed weeks later but it wasn't
yeah the gas leak was takin care yeah
keeps your paranoia thing bought my
hands hurts
I don't think I got that leak yeah well
and that might have been the case here I
mean some people in this town by the
so afraid of this person who may well
have existed yeah that you know
psychosomatically they're causing these
symptoms like oh my god I feel sick I
feel somebody that sprayed yes I have to
get people to come over so do you smell
any gas no no I smell gas No so that
went on for a couple weeks yeah off and
on you notice I think maybe some of the
attacks were real and I think there are
other ones were like what happened to me
it was paranoia the interesting thing
about this and I actually remembered
this short story from my childhood in
the 1930s there was actually kind of a
very popular short story called the
night the bed fell by famous American
humorist James Thurber and this was in a
pretty widely available compilation at
the time her book at the time and it had
to do with a woman who had a paranoid
fear that someone was going to put a
tube under her bedroom door and spray
chloroform into her room and knock her
out right and I remember this story
because I used to have a book like
famous American humorous stories or
whatever from the 30s or whatever and I
had read that story and it's actually
very funny it's a very funny story it's
making fun of this woman so it could be
that this was where the idea came from
her it became conflated with that yeah
because this story did come out before
even before the Virginia attacks I
believe so it could have been that but
like I said I do think that there might
have been something behind this it was
only later on after the story got picked
up by 40 and researchers and stuff like
that that people started saying that it
was that there was some supernatural or
maybe it was an extraterrestrial or
something which why would then have to
be like I said you don't have to be
supernatural to put some weird gas in a
good gun and go around spraying into
people's weapons it was the 1930s gasses
were popular so maybe that was a popular
fear in in the minds of people of gas
leaks that's true they weren't that -
they weren't that far away from the gas
lights you know they probably used gas
for cooking and other things and there's
lots of little you know gas was a common
concept so with something that might you
might be afraid of kind of like today
you'd be afraid of radiation I can
remember in the eighties were terrified
of radon gas yeah I remember that just
because a couple houses were found to
have great
gasps right kill you yeah okay quick
like you said and particularly in that
period you know between the wars and
stuff like that you know gas attacks and
yeah like you said it was it was a very
common household thing so that might
have been where a lot of the fears came
from like I said not not that I'm saying
that this wasn't an actual person that
might have pulled a few of these
how many reported gas attacks were there
I lost count that many honestly the the
ones that took place in Virginia in the
1930s that's a [ __ ] ton yeah yeah we
reported to the police yeah I mean as
far as I can tell okay
none of them like I said none of them
are super crazy no no one's saying like
spring-heeled Jack kind of stuff like he
was you know flying or anything it's
just you know people reporting there was
a funny smell in my house I got
paralyzed you know yeah as I said though
you know the whole mad gasser phenomenon
I kind of feel like yeah a lot of it
might have been mass hysteria yeah but I
kind of think that there was maybe a
couple things that really happened that
that led to the later masses there I
don't think the whole thing was now
completely imagination
it looks like the reported cases number
in the hundreds yeah I probably think
you know maybe 10% of those were
probably based on real things so that
still dozens yeah maybe even dozens of
these attacks in the 30s yeah and like I
said the interesting thing too because
remember I said that the the earlier
some of the earlier reports that
happened in Virginia they had seen a
woman's shoe prints outside of the
window actually I think one of the
latest reports that happened in Mattoon
Illinois they also reported seeing
high-heeled shoes oh well I don't know
if it was the same person like she
replaced the place but but you know
interesting detail this say two thousand
or twenty attacks one person could do
that in that town oh yeah in that given
period of time and that could cause a
panic and you could have hundreds of
reports even though it was really only a
couple dozen actual gases and I kind of
feel like that's what happened something
along that lines until until we know
more that's you know it's gonna be
impossible to find out what all it was
just too long ago but yeah possible yeah
and then before we go I wanted to go
briefly into this other very famous
story
The Devil's footprints I've heard of
this one now this happened in 1855 all
right now it happened in Devon in
England okay there was a very heavy
snowfall over that night of February
1855 and evidently many people when they
came out of their houses the next
morning there was a very very long trail
of hoof prints in the snow this trail
supposedly ran some sources say 40 miles
some say a hundred miles the weirdest
thing about it is that the trail would
go like sometimes it would it would go
up to a house and then the hoofprints
would be on the roof and then they would
be on the other side of the house as
though there were also some where it
would walk up to like a little drain
yeah and then it would be they would put
prints would go up to the drain and then
they would start again on the other side
of the drain and things of that nature
right now the hoof prints were about
four inches long three inches across
between 8 and 16 inches apart and mostly
in a single file which would indicate
that this was a hoofed animal that was
walking on two legs
meaning the devil man I ain't so now
here's the thing I'm already I already
have it in my mind what cast or this is
yeah there is little direct evidence of
the phenomena there is some stuff from
the time where somebody you know drew
the little things and what they look
like everything however the only known
documents from the time actually came
out later they were found later in the
1950s where they actually kind of talked
about it the story is very famous now as
the night debt the devil walked in Devon
I think that's what that's what it was
called in my book right the book that I
have it reports all this weird stuff is
you know this really happened
they don't really back anything up but
the problem with this story is that and
and I was kind of thinking this too it's
like one how did they know yeah that
this trail went from 40 to 100 miles
have to follow along we'd have to follow
the whole challenge
attract a bear a bear Israelite I
challenge you to go track a bear and
very hard to track an animal and another
thing too is that you know various
people said that they saw these
footprints in you know different parts
of the county but sometimes their
descriptions of them were different and
here's the thing and I think this story
later went to that some of the hoof
prints could have been a horse some bad
thing well yeah well no I was gonna say
that some of the later story said that
it was some of the footprints look like
they've been burned so I think those
kind of came about later you know when
what the whole devil thing happened the
problem with it is that one you're
having differing descriptions of what
what they look like and there are a lot
of animals that could have left those
footprints and then people saw them in
different parts of the county and just
thought it was one big one big that's
the thing that's really getting me what
are you gonna do back in the 1850s
you're you're you're in your town you go
look at those footprints first of all it
shouldn't have footprints there from the
day before I mean even animal footprints
because you know there's people with
horses well it's no it's not overnight
yeah okay you wake up in the morning you
may be in a small town you might find
some strange footprints yeah but how are
you gonna know that they go for a
hundred miles you can't take your cell
phone and then call the new footprints
over there and then it's the same animal
it's just not gonna happen
those the logistics aren't gonna be
possible for the 1850s so that's what
I'm thinking - no and honestly they're
like even if there had been ones that
like appeared on rooftops and stuff like
that there's like there's animals that
could have done that like you know what
I mean there's like little hopping
rodents yeah like like little wood mice
that jump and the little footprints that
they leave kind of like cloven hooves as
their little butts as the Sun comes up
people are waking up across all the
towns everywhere and they're going
they're spoiling these footprints and
they're not all paying attention to him
so those footprints if they were there
wouldn't be intact for long it just just
no this this story sounds like something
that would appear in one of those
old-fashioned newspapers yeah like
folks people that's the sound it does
sound like that yeah and like I said
even if there were I mean you know some
of them could have been a horse some
like one pastor even said well maybe a
kangaroo like a state from the zoo or
something like that there's this one guy
named Jeffrey household and he said that
the Devonport Dockyard they said that
they had this weird experimental balloon
that had these shackle things on the
bottom and they're like now if this
thing had gone across the something like
of course it would never hit those trees
on the tree line well yeah yeah of
course yeah that's what people have said
well you know that might have gotten
Carlos plausible explanation for this
just so far just off the top my head
this is a hoax newspaper just made yeah
kind of like the 40 and you know flying
pterodactyls found in caves yeah where
where it was just kind of a hoax from
the hosts from the very beginning and no
and it just gets kind of well and it at
the time because yeah it was they were
trolling and everybody understood the
troll they understood what the beam was
interestingly in Devon in 2009 there was
another trail a similar trail found but
they think that was probably somebody
better I'd like doing it because they
knew the story right about the end of
the Devon Devils foot path and stuff so
like who I'm gonna do is in 2009 and
we'll be on the news and [ __ ] like that
so yeah this one I just wanted to add
this one at the end because it's it's
usually or and it's short and it's kind
of it's usually tied in with
spring-heeled Jack for whatever reason
big difference does Spring Heeled Jack I
blew that that happened that that was
probably yeah God believe that the mad
gasser
that's from yeah something it's based on
something that happened this this this
is yeah this one I think is was just a
fanciful or like I said even if there
were footprints then it was just animal
footprints might have been a badger
might have been a mouse and they didn't
go for a hundred miles no way I
challenge you to find an animal
footprints
know that how would they assist in that
you couldn't travel 100 bottles in a day
back you couldn't confirm him so yeah I
think that one is probably largely the
devil didn't walk through Devon England
don't worry about it you guys alright so
we've gone over so I'm going to end the
show right now I hope you enjoyed the
Sun kind of folkloric episode you know
kind of fun and remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe and share
with all your friends if you'd like to
financially support the show check out
our patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock or go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation if you haven't checked
out our latest movie review it was
beyond re animator so go check that out
also check out our Zazzle store at
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock in there are
t-shirts and a tote bag there that you
may purchase if you desire and that'll
do it for episode 92 we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
you